i just had a very intense physical
release
and the physical release felt
very much like a
like discharge like a trauma
discharge there seems to be
an accumulation
of stress
and stressors
that are
absorbed in the body
somatically right it's like that line
that says that our cells are a
technology that turns experience into
biology and so the accumulation of micro
stressors and micro traumas in our lives
um
it starts to build and we become kind of
like a pressure cooker and
the more
the pressure cooker valve is pushed to
its limits the more
we develop sort of the side effects of
increased neuroticism and rumination the
accumulation of those stressors makes us
more neurotic and can be catalyzing
diseases of despair can trigger
episodes of of of of microaggression of
depression of increased feelings of
anxiety at first at faint disquiet but
eventually a fibrillating anxiousness
that you carry with you in a kind of
perpetual hyper vigilance and if you
don't make space for that physical
release if you do not release if you do
not discharge
you
the the weight of the world
becomes unsustainable right like too
much of the mundane will crush you and
and and
and i think when when dostoyevsky said
that all men lead lives of quiet
desperation i think he was speaking to
men that have no outlet
for this physical release you know i
think that dostoyevsky was speaking to
those of us that have found no spaces
for discharge
when we don't have spaces for discharge
i think we become sick
i think we become ill i think we develop
pathologies i think we become miserable
i think we become desperate i think we
become aggressive i think we become
ticking time bombs i think we become
michael douglas in the film falling down
the opening sequence as he sits there on
the 405 traffic those dead souls in
their metal coffins we become ticking
time bombs we become pressure cookers
and we become in need of an urgent
intervention before we explode in a way
that is not healthy we need to find
places to dissipate those stressors to
act out our inner life to perform an
exorcism of our neuroticism
with a kind of release with a kind of
discharge this is where medicine like
mdma psychotherapy can take somebody
with treatment resistant ptsd and make
them shake and heal their grief through
discharge through trauma release through
somatic trauma release
i had an experience under the water
today
i guess from the
suspension
of
the sense of having to stand you know
floating in the water with my eyes
closed um being taken for a ride
was was immediately it gave rise to
profound discharge and profound release
i felt myself purring like a cat
grunting it was a guttural it was in the
body and i kept going involuntarily
what is that well that is release that
is physical release that something is
being metabolized dissipated discharged
you know it's going out through your
extremities and guttural ecstasy and
quaking annihilating glory and i find
that for me like if i don't have regular
interventions of those kinds of
discharges i become a more neurotic
person
i i feel like i am a ticking time bomb
at the precipice of disjointment every
every day i'm walking around you know
like terrified that a schism is about to
occur and i'm gonna explode like michael
douglas and falling down or jerry
maguire when he first gets fired he says
i know what everybody's thinking that
i'm about to freak out you know we're
all at the edge of the freak out
unless we find healthy spaces and
outlets to act out our inner life and
have this trauma discharge i am a person
that needs physical release and i am a
person that does not have enough
physical release i need more love making
in my life i need more ego annihilating
voluntary deaths of the ego in
deep embodiment written or rich
embodiment deep embodiment rich
environments and high consequence as
jamie weil says
it's healthcare it's healthcare that is
it's soul care yes soul care
it's soul care and it should be promoted
yes the times we're living yes we're
living through like you know pandemic
yeah in a hundred years yes and most of
us are like just like so wound up and so
penned up and so just like
heads on sticks you know no embodiment
no digesting our grief no dissipating
our angst no discharge
and no trauma release and so
we have to heal ourselves we have to
move away from being these perpetual
pressure cookers at the edge of despair
you know living lives of quiet
desperation and we need instead
to create spaces and
spaces and places where we can spend
evenings uttering ejaculations of
amazement whereas once we were blind now
we
the beauty the radiance the love songs
the moments that take our breath away
and make us whole again
may you find those places and spaces
friends may you release
and free the brave reckless god that
lives within you
amen we protect it yes
and protect it